yes I'm afraid I am a bit naive when it  comes to the weaker sex  Freddie Benson and you are Lawrence  Jamison you're married aren't you you  can tell listen we're the weaker sex men  don't live as long as women we get more  heart attacks more strokes more prostate  trouble I say it's time for a change I  say let them give us money let's live  off them for a while stop being so sorry  of yourself it's unbearable what so you  think we might have put a few people out  of business today that's all for naught  but you've been doing that every day for  almost 40 years Sam and if this is all  for naught then so is everything out  there it's just money it's made up  pieces of paper with pictures on it so  we don't have to kill each other just to  get something to eat it's not wrong and  it's certainly no different today  because everything